how's it going I'm here to pass and I'm
CaptainSparklez and this is the Disney
infinity 3.0 showdown ladies and
gentlemen
yes this is a DAT battle okay now that
vs. yes where I am gonna get points
so whoever dismember each other yeah
let's do one where we both try and board
each other ship I've never ever does it
quicker here we go infiltrate
infiltration is going on wait I'm so
lost what happened the camera action
don't shoot me I'm your lover and we
actually are yeah yeah show some respect
okay you're not my way for the yes I am
shy no you're not yes I am what is it
cutie who are I don't I can't oh my god
oh my god I understand your struggle
that no come here you're not here no
you're not get away from me I'm
destroying your vehicle
yes don't don't we obviously decided
what we did you already stop shooting me
all right here yes oh no I spit all over
the place tonight I present
and you get that Jaime I don't know art
eggs okay
os we'll be taking him down together
okay so the right side I did it that was
myself oh okay wait I got this I got
this
alright good job Thanks
teamwork whoa also it looks you out han
Solo
he's gonna do it for his lover he's
gonna do it solo yeah this is my job
nope let's fly together oh wait oh no no
no no no no let me go put me down no
wait teamwork yeah you really invented
me it's right there it's right there in
front we do it just to there we go yeah
I'm going to throw you I tried to use me
as a pair you almost threw me out this
is okay I'm very comfortable you this is
great for my back here we go
no you're shooting the addition getting
in my ship you got to get in your ship
oh yeah you're right sorry sorry I need
to charge my ship look at the only look
at it why aren't you looking don't you
come in don't you I'm doing it steel
Mike the hard way don't steal my glory
well steal whatever was right yeah we go
there we go
you went red you went red I'm good I've
got it oh that was teamwork
yeah we're on Endor racing speed bike
like a sheep
Luke hey and oh here we go okay so we
need to collect as many gates as
possible get req I don't know what
you're doing I don't know either
what are you actually I'm just chilling
why am i oh yeah you know let's say
they're Luke's say say no wait dang I
think look Luke Luke I'm gonna wreck you
no that's right Luke Ricky oh stop oh
you killed your brother dude there's
like a lot of new stuff there's so much
stuff I don't I can't I
you know what it would be great maybe we
get producer we use our super YouTube
powers and summon a producer let's do
that how do we do it though with someone
I'm hearing okay right here okay
Matt the producer matter hey guys how
you doing okay so you remember that
iconic part at the end of our beginning
of empire when they escaped from Hoth
you actually eight to play it in our
game okay so yes go ahead and get out of
this menu and what start playing all
right
Zuzu what am i controlling right now so
the left into ER the personally I don't
even know anything oz badass dodgy job
running into everything at all okay wait
you're the Falcon yeah I ate your dish
how oh you can flick right or left on
the thumb stick and do barrel rolls and
stuff to avoid income
I'm sorry I'm sorry
what is this planet made of and you get
cool results at the end of all these is
the fun like on Rails flying sections
that we have all throughout the empire
playset so it's like really really cool
and glad we could summon you hey I'm
glad I could be yeah so this is
literally the beginning of the Twilight
or the Republic playset this is another
one of the play sets that we have in
Disney infinity so we have a bunch of
Twilight figures here a nice which ones
you're gonna play you can play is
obi-wan Anakin ahsoka or Yoda we can
you've already stolen notice I'm gonna
go with Anakin then I wanted to catch
him okay I'll go with that again yeah
can't go wrong very good all right
before you mean what's right and wrong
really yeah you look like someone I want
to cuddle and win I know I'm pretty
thank you all right here we go ahead but
he's awesome so the guys that are
helping develop this place that are
Ninja Theory Ninja Theory are the guys
that did games like heavenly sword and
devil may cry very very cool bunch of
people out of the UK and yeah they've
been plugging away with this and working
on all of our combat inside of infinity
so it all could be you know that's cool
I want to try it out the story is the
Troy factory starts back up you want to
find out who's doing it that's why
you're here
yeah if you hold down the circle button
you're actually going oh look at that
that's not Lee that is he normally is
very word for that yeah try something
real cool you can actually hold down
triangle and you'll like swipe them up
into the air and you can do aircon oh
okay
that's the right word and with Anakin 2
you can actually keep that going for
almost ever because you can do force
pole on guys oh my god you can combo it
oh yeah totally
that's cool all right yeah that's like
one of the big things like we wanted to
add like all these best in breed for
parole yeah so like you know normally
like you know kids and family games are
like really really simple yeah and this
gives it a yeah so like for us like we
can actually learn timing and so our
hardcore players like we can get some
sick combos going exactly yeah so guys I
know you guys have been having a ton of
fun doing split screens but you know you
can play it online right that sounds
epic
wait anything we didn't have to sit next
to each other the whole time oh my god
Oh Dave's my entire day why didn't you
say this before
okay do we still have to stand next to
each other though yes dude that's brutal
all right guys so here it is you guys
are gonna play the Sarlacc pit what the
goal with this is is to knock the other
guy into the Sarlacc pit and win pretty
simple now that simple yet sounds like a
plan what do you thinks gonna score the
most we or most victories I have to say
myself obviously who do you think is you
should know right sir side side right
now so yeah we got so yeah we got Darth
Maul over here and we are so katana so
we got the perfect Jedi mashup you guys
like all set remember all the combat
moves all that good stuff no yes they
will come to me I feel like it yeah sure
you just use the Force in your brain
different your mouth as you can see like
there's the barge there's a bunch of
different platforms whatever you do
don't touch the ground touch the ground
you're toast
so you have about three minutes to see
how many times you can knock the other
guy off I my tactic
my tactic well just to wait for you to
jump in yeah that's not very nice of you
oh there you are
yeah I got the force dude I have the
force too oh man this is my game I'm not
even fair this is great
no yeah quick recovery don't know yeah
oh what the yo okay you got your got
your got your there's no coming back
from this
you're okay damn it I hope I was tasty
at least you're pretty terrible like I'm
bad with your elf
thanks man oh you're welcome yeah like
kind words everything no way glad I'm
here to support them oh you're dead no
I'm not dead yeah you're pretty I'm
being but that's not awesome what's
happening
what what you lots it's obvious that I
want but fine we'll let you guys decide
who won so please tell us in the
comments who you think won I believe I
may have had style points you know he
did some sick flips and something
exactly yeah remember our best trick
contest I won that he said never
specifically said you won I just said
you landed good ok well it's up to you
guys
oh boy today today that best trick
contest was pretty awesome there was
some cool rolls into asteroids there was
that there was a little bit of laughing
a little bit of crying there was some
leg decapitation yeah yeah leg
amputation yeah there was that some good
stuff and at the end of the day no
matter what the what you decide who's
crowns the victor yeah we had a good day
we had a good day yeah it was a lot of
fun yep we'll see you next time man
you good I'm yeah let's go